merci beaucoup
mes chers collègues
notre mission d'information poursuit ses
auditions en recevant cet après-midi
monsieur
Erwin pas en forme
vice-président de la branche mondiale
énergie hydrogène du groupe Air Liquide
vous êtes accompagné de Monsieur Pierre
Cavelan responsa des affaires publiques
pour la pour la France
je vous rappelle je rappelle à tout le
monde que cette réunion est captée et
elle est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat sur lequel elle pourra
être consultée en vidéo à la demande
monsieur le vice-président notre mission
d'information comprend des membres issus
des différentes commissions du Sénat et
représente l'ensemble des groupes
politiques de cette assemblée le
développement des filières de
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert représente un
enjeu important pour permettre à la
France et à l'Union européenne
d'atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050 mais c'est
aussi pour notre souveraineté et la
compétitivité de notre économie des
enjeux extrêmement
importants après avoir entendu de
nombreux acteurs publics qui se penchent
sur les stratégies à mettre en oeuvre
des centres de réflexion et des
organismes de recherche il nous importe
d'avoir la vision des industriels et
singulièrement des producteurs d'énergie
premièrement pour comprendre comment
votre groupe
s'adapte à l'ambition européenne qui se
dessine qui constituent à certains
égards un véritable changement de
paradigme dans le domaine de la mobilité
deuxièmement pour apprécier ce que
représente les perspectives de
développement de biocarburant des
carburantes synthèse et de l'hydrogène
vert dans le portefeuille d'activité
d'un groupe comme Air Liquide
troisièmement pour analyser ce qui peut
aujourd'hui freiner le développement de
ces filières que ce soit sur le plan
réglementaire sur le plan technique ou
en termes d'accompagnement fiscal ou
financier
nous avons bien conscience que la France
et l'Union européenne n'évoluent pas
dans une bulle isolée du reste du monde
et que nous devons faire face à des
stratégies de développement
industrielles très ambitieux voir
agressive de la part de certains états
je pense évidemment à l'IRA américain
Air Liquide étant présent dans 73 pays à
travers le monde vous pourrez nous faire
part de votre visio vision des enjeux en
la matière nous comprenons des
stratégies qui se dessinent que
l'hydrogène vert et les carburants de
synthèse sont appelés à contribuer de
manière significative à la décarbonation
de certains modes de transport en
particulier la mobilité lourde plusieurs
personnes auditionnées ont toutefois
souligné la rareté des ressources
disponibles
les besoins en électricité nécessaire
pour atteindre les objectifs de
décarbonation fixée par l'Union
européenne et notamment pour produire de
l'hydrogène vert seront très élevés or
la capacité à produire de l'électricité
des carbonée à hauteur de ses besoins
apparaît un certain nous avons de fait
devant nous un mur d'investissement le
point de vue du groupe Air Liquide nous
intéresse évidemment tout
particulièrement tout comme votre
analyse concernant les débats en cours
au niveau de l'Union européenne pour
prendre en compte de manière adéquate la
contribution de l'hydrogène décarbonée
au même type que l'hydrogène
renouvelable
notre rapporteur monsieur Vincent capo
canelas qui est à l'origine de cette
mission vous a adressé un questionnaire
qui peut vous servir mais ce qui nous
apporte dans votre propos liminaire ça a
été évidemment votre vision stratégique
des enjeux que nous aborderons au
travers de cette mission
je passerai ensuite la parole à notre
rapporteur puis à l'ensemble de mes
collègues afin qu'il puisse vous
relancer et vous poser un certain nombre
de questions vous pourrez nous
transmettre
ultérieurement des réponses écrites aux
questions qui vous ont été adressées par
notre rapporteur
monsieur le vice-président je vous cède
la parole pour une quinzaine de minutes
merci monsieur le Président
permettez-moi donc de me présenter à une
fournisse en charge de l'activité
mobilité pour le groupe Air Liquide
je travaille au sein du groupe depuis un
peu plus d'une vingtaine d'années et
puis dans le domaine de l'hydrogène déjà
depuis une quinzaine d'années j'ai eu
l'occasion de par mes fonctions encore
récentes notamment de diriger cette
activité au Japon et donc d'être
particulièrement en prise avec le
secteur et la montée du secteur sur
l'Asie toute la zone Asie Pacifique
quelques mots de description sur le
groupe Air Liquide tout d'abord donc un
groupe qui a 120 ans on est leader
un des leaders mondiaux des gaz
industriels donc on fournit ces gaz là
une variété de d'industrie depuis les
industries lourdes
jusqu'à des secteurs plus spécialisés
comme l'électronique ou la santé
le monde hospitalier la santé à domicile
vous l'avez dit nous sommes présents
dans 73 pays ça représente à peu près 2
millions de clients industriels de
millions de patients qu'on accompagne
au-delà du fait que le groupe Air
Liquide a été un des pionniers en France
et même plus largement sur
l'inspiration le développement d'une
filière hydrogène on est nous-mêmes
impliqué dans le dans le secteur de
l'hydrogène depuis près de 60 ans il
faut se rappeler les origines du
programme Marianne le programme spatial
puis ensuite tout un ensemble
d'investissements pour désulfurer les
carburants l'hydrogène étant une une
molécule essentielle dans cette
opération là donc on maîtrise le groupe
à liquide maîtrise aujourd'hui
l'ensemble de la chaîne
depuis la production jusqu'à
distribution d'hydrogène l'ensemble des
technologies associées c'est aussi une
des choses qui nous caractérise on est
particulièrement impliqué et active dans
le développement des technologies on
construit nous-mêmes nos propres usines
qu'on exploite pour fournir l'hydrogène
à nos clients
si je prends un tout petit peu de recul
sur les engagements climats du groupe
Air Liquide et nos autres activités donc
on est engagé depuis plusieurs années
dans une dans un dans un plan climat
avec des objectifs
très ambitieux donc on a annoncé
une réduction de 33% de nos émissions
d'ici 2035 évidemment pour viser notre
réalité carbone en 2050 malgré le fait
qu'on soit une industrie
particulièrement intensive en énergie
on vise une inflexion de nos émissions
de CO2 à l'horizon 2025 et donc ensuite
une baisse pour baisser déjà d'un tiers
à l'horizon 2035 le plan d'entreprise
advance que le groupe a
présenté l'année dernière
reflète vraiment cette ambition avec des
objectifs financiers et maintenant des
objectifs extra-financiers sur les 16
milliards d'investissements que le
groupe Air Liquide va réaliser sur la
durée de ce plan là 50% de ses
investissements sont directement liés à
la transition énergétique donc on parle
de l'hydrogène on parle de toutes les
projets de captage et de stockage du CO2
des projets d'efficacité énergétique
plus plus généralement
on a plus spécifiquement sur la partie
hydrogène annoncé également un plan
maintenant il y a plus de deux ans de
cela puis en investissement de 8000
milliards d'euros dans la décennie le
but pour nous étant à cette horizon là
déjà de tripler notre activité hydrogène
d'investir des capacités de production
d'hydrogène décarbonée par exemple 3 Go
de l'heure de 3 gigawatts d'électrolyse
au-delà de cette introduction alors je
voudrais revenir sur un point de
terminologie qui aidera aussi une partie
des propos que j'aurais par la suite
parce que l'intitulé de la mission parle
d'hydrogène vert et je veux juste
clarifier le référentiel qu'on utilise
en lien notamment avec la terminologie
européenne qui date qui date de 2020
on distingue pour un pour notre part
l'hydrogène renouvelable donc
véritablement l'hydrogène produit à
partir d'électricité d'origine
renouvelable par le procédé
d'électrolyse un cycle la production à
partir de biométhane dans des unités de
réformage tel qu'il en existe déjà
aujourd'hui
et à côté de cette hydrogène
renouvelable on a l'hydrogène bas
carbone qui permet donc de produire un
de l'hydrogène à faible empreinte de CO2
soit toujours par cette technologie
d'électrolyse en utilisant de
l'électricité nucléaire soit en
utilisant des procédés à partir
d'énergie fossile et captage de CO2 pour
pour stockage et c'est très important
parce que on voit que dans un certain
nombre de régions du monde c'est
l'aspect car hydrogène bas carbone qui
prime avec véritablement l'empreinte CO2
de cette hydrogène quel que soit son
origine donc j'emploie le mode
d'hydrogène renouvelable d'hydrogène bas
carbone selon les cas je ferai parfois
aussi le raccourci CCS quand je parle de
captage du CO2 donc captage et stockage
du CO2
avant de continuer de plus plus
spécifiquement vous vous décrire la
vision du groupe Air Liquide pour
développer promouvoir le rôle de
l'hydrogène dans la transition
énergétique je voudrais juste saluer les
avancées sur la stratégie
française de développement d'hydrogène
sur durant ces dernières années comme je
disais j'étais moi-même
impliqué dans le développement j'aide
l'écosystème depuis une quinzaine
d'années on a démarré à l'époque avec
des activités fortes du CEA des
développements académiques ont été
véritablement dans dans une phase de R&D
on a franchi manifestement un cap majeur
ces dernières années les technologies
sont prêtes aujourd'hui
pour être déployés sur sur les marchés
et de manière encore plus importante on
peut vraiment voir le rôle que le
gouvernement a joué également via le
Conseil national de l'hydrogène ces
dernières années pour véritablement
structurer une vraie stratégie hydrogène
autour de certains piliers industriel à
des carbonnés puis un pilier mobilité
donc on a quand même réussi à regrouper
les acteurs industriels français Dieu
sait qu'on a de nombreux acteurs qui qui
sont particulièrement pertinents sur le
sujet
alors notre vision pour le groupe Air
Liquide de l'hydrogène et des
conditions importantes pour le succès de
cet hydrogène pour que ils puissent
jouer tout son rôle dans la transition
énergétique donc je pense que un certain
nombre de personnes ont en tête avec à
l'horizon 2050 l'hydrogène peut
représenter de l'ordre de 20% du mix
énergétique une fois qu'on a dit ça il
est important de voir où est-ce que
l'hydrogène est véritablement pertinent
et le but étant pas de l'utiliser dans
dans n'importe quelle application donc
pour faire très simple c'est une
solution
qui est idéale pour tous les secteurs
les plus difficiles à décarboner et
véritablement pour apporter une
résilience à notre système énergétique
donc quand je dis la solution pour les
secteurs les plus difficiles à
décarboner c'est à dire les secteurs
pour lesquels on n'a pas d'autres
alternatives par exemple via de
l'électrification directe qui serait
viable
pérenne et vér simplement
adapté pour passer à l'échelle et quand
je parle de d'un bénéfice en termes de
résilience pour notre système
énergétique c'est véritablement par
rapport aux énergies renouvelables on
voit qu'on va vers un système qui sera
fortement basé sur ces énergies
renouvelables on a absolument besoin de
solutions pour être capable de stocker
de l'énergie transporter de l'énergie
depuis les régions on va dire plus
riches en énergie renouvelable vers les
points de consommation et gérer de
manière générale l'intermittence
donc deux gros piliers importants le
Conseil national de l'hydrogène et
s'appuie également dessus tout d'abord
un pilier d'utilisation d'hydrogène pour
le secteur industriel on voit que là
dans l'industrie le domaine de
l'industrie lourde donc on parle ici du
raffinage de la chimie de la sidérurgie
potentiellement également de des
cimenteries l'hydrogène et une solution
assez évidente pour des carboner ces
secteurs et c'est certainement des
domaines à prioriser dans les années qui
viennent ça permet d'attaquer le sujet
via des grands bassins industriels
existants de massifier à moindre coût à
moindre coût et à moindre effort des
installations de production donc
d'hydrogène renouvelable ou d'hydrogène
bas carbone à partir de CCS et donc de
bâtir une base de production compétitive
d'hydrogène décarbonée dans dans la
décennie donc quand on regarde les
objectifs français
fixé par le CNH donc pour arrondir de
l'ordre de 1 million de tonnes par an
d'hydrogène d'ici 2030 à produire ou si
on regarde le plan ripower io de la
Commission européenne on est sur une
vingtaine de millions de tonnes 10
millions en domestiques et 10 millions
potentiellement d'un port on voit que
c'est secteurs industriels que
j'évoquais précédemment vont être clés
pour bâtir cette base de production donc
ça nous semble un pilier essentiel
pour attaquer ensuite
un deuxième pilier qui est la
décarbonation de la mobilité du secteur
de la mobilité vous le mentionnez tout à
l'heure
en introduction alors là aussi la même
la même logique prévaut
c'est que l'hydrogène doit permettre de
décarboner les applications de la
mobilité les plus difficiles
à traiter donc quand on regarde un petit
peu par ordre de mérite ce qui peut être
électrifié doit être électif électrifiée
donc bon on voit aujourd'hui évidemment
le transport ferroviaire avec une
électrification des lignes les véhicules
passagers
véhicule légers sont des bons candidats
pour une électrification à partir de
batterie
l'étape suivante on voit le rôle des
biocarburants ou agrocarburant mais qui
sont de fait limitées en termes de
capacité de de ressources biomasse
disponibles et vient donc ensuite
derrière unique solution
des dérivés hydrogènes on n'a pas
d'autre solution pour décarboner
certaines franges du transport routier
l'aérien le maritime ou une partie du
ferroviaire donc on va vraiment le rôle
indispensable de l'hydrogène mais se
pose à partir de là quelques questions
la première question est sous quelle
forme
utiliser
cette hydrogène donc soit j'ai envie de
dire sous forme d'hydrogène lui-même que
l'hydrogène soit stockée sous forme
gazeuse ou liquide donc
cryogénique basse température
soit sous forme d'ammoniac dans certains
secteurs j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure
l'ammoniac est un dérivé permettant de
stocker l'hydrogène sans aucune émission
de CO2 lorsqu'il est utilisée soit sous
forme de carburant synthétique durable
donc ils font l'objet notamment de cette
mission là donc comme il a dû être déjà
dit précédemment ces carburants étant
produit à partir de l'hydrogène
renouvelable de CO2 biogénique
et permettre de recréer des carburants
liquides très proches de ceux qui sont
utilisés aujourd'hui donc chacune de ces
formes là à ces avantages et ses
inconvénients les carburants durables
synthétiques on le bénéfice de pouvoir
remplacer très facilement ce qu'on ce
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
malheureusement sont très consommateurs
d'hydrogène pour les produire le coût de
production qui évalué aujourd'hui nous
on l'estime environ à 5 fois le coup
d'un carburant du carburant qui va être
remplacé
donc ça pose quand même un vrai un vrai
sujet quand à la viabilité de son usage
et par ailleurs on re libère le CO2
quand bien même il est d'origine
biogénique on est quand même sur un
cycle où on met des émissions de CO2 le
mentionnais ensuite l'ammoniaque
l'ammoniac à l'intérêt de ne pas
réémettre ce CO2 et déjà moins pratique
à stocker que ces carburants durables à
des enjeux de toxicité donc c'est ça qui
aujourd'hui réduit son potentiel dans
certaines dans un certain nombre
d'applications et ensuite reste donc
l'hydrogène donc sous forme gazeuse sous
forme liquide qui finalement je dirais
n'a aucun des inconvénients que j'ai
cité précédemment il va être plus
économique à produire que des carburants
synthétiques il est pas toxique n'aurait
aimé pas de CO2 par contre nécessite
pour être stocké facilement de monter
dans des niveaux de pression ou des
basses températures donc finalement des
nouvelles technologies et le groupe Air
Liquide nous on est particulièrement
engagé pour développer ces technologies
et justement montrer le potentiel de
l'hydrogène utiliser directement dans
toutes ces applications et j'y
reviendrai pour les balayer rapidement
la deuxième question pour nous qui se
pose ensuite de manière claire quand on
regarde l'introduction de l'hydrogène
dans ces secteurs de la mobilité c'est
quels sont les bonnes stratégies de
transition pour introduire l'hydrogène
et quels sont les stratégies de
transformation vous indiquez tout à
l'heure le mot de changement de
paradigme c'est vraiment ça le sujet
quand on pour décarboner la mobilité on
parle d'un remplacement la plupart du
temps des véhicules eux-mêmes on parle
d'investissement massif
d'infrastructures de ravitaillement ou
de recharge et puis ensuite on parle de
l'ensemble de la chaîne de David Heyman
en hydrogène
faut avoir en tête que pour passer tout
ça à l'échelle on pas on parle de
filière entière à des développer donc
des filières de nouveaux équipements de
nouveaux composants des investissements
massifs à tous les niveaux de la filière
et beaucoup de coordination beaucoup de
coordination entre les différents
acteurs de la filière et aujourd'hui
c'est dans un certain nombre de casques
qui ce qui pêche encore
d'être capable d'accorder tout le monde
sur une même une même trajectoire c'est
pour ça que on voit et nous pour l'avoir
expérimenté aussi bien aux États-Unis
dans des pays d'Asie en Europe
l'importance d'avoir des des politiques
de soutien des politiques
d'accompagnement qui soient fines par
rapport à ces enjeux là qui impliquent
forcément une certaine complexité pour
les adapter dans le temps donc avant
d'aller avant de rentrer secteur par
secteur les quelques les quelques enjeux
là vraiment que ça soulève c'est un
enjeu d'articulation entre ces deux
grands piliers que j'indique j'ai
indiqué précédemment on développe une
capacité d'hydrogène pour l'industrie on
veut utiliser cette hydrogène ensuite
également pour la mobilité on a un vrai
besoin d'articuler ces deux mondes ça
implique notamment des schémas
industriels plus centralisés qui peuvent
aller à l'encontre de certaines visions
qui décentraliseraient davantage
pousserai à des petites sources de
production d'hydrogène localisées je
peux citer l'exemple en Île-de-France
par exemple proche des lieux d'usage il
nous semble nous et l'expérience le
monde beaucoup plus économique et
efficace de centraliser via des plus
grandes unités de production
un deuxième enjeu quand on trade de la
mobilité c'est véritablement que ces
politiques de soutien
traitent
tous ensemble des trois composantes de
l'offre de nouveau donc le soutien aux
véhicules à l'infrastructure de
recherche et au carburant lui-même sous
diverses formes mais à partir du moment
où l'un de ces trois éléments est oublié
on voit qu'on a tout de suite beaucoup
plus de mal à faire émerger la filière
un troisième enjeu important c'est quoi
faut toujours avoir en tête qu'on part
véritablement de quasiment zéro dans ces
secteurs là donc la logique d'activation
et absolument
critique et pour permettre cette logique
d'activation on a besoin de flexibilité
dans le système on voit aujourd'hui des
contraintes qui sont mises parfois en
contrepartie d'un mécanisme de soutien
sur des règles très prescriptives en
termes d'origine de l'hydrogène
justement de schémas industriels de
production on
subit le cas parfois même en France
on voit un vrai risque que ce type de de
conditions nuisent à un essor rapide de
la filière alors que d'autres pays sont
au contraire en train de en train
d'accélérer
et le dernier point qui nous semble
important toujours dans ces enjeux je
dirais de un peu de haut niveau c'est au
niveau national de diversifier les
approches les solutions
de décarbonation qui sont visés pour ces
différents secteurs être capable pour
donner quelques exemples de soutenir à
la fois un développement d'une filière
batterie pour les véhicules en même
temps qu'une filière hydrogène
ou quand on va être dans l'aviation une
filière de carburant durable en même
temps qu'une filière hydrogène liquide
c'est il en va de la capacité à
des risques les enjeux technologiques
qu'on pourrait rencontrer dans les
années futures
donc voilà c'est principaux enjeux mais
qui résument nous en tant que
capteur véritablement engagé dans le
développement de la filière les
principaux éléments auxquels on se
confronte je voudrais traiter très
rapidement de deux secteurs si vous me
permettez spécifiquement la mobilité
routière et l'aviation la mobilité
routière pourquoi le rôle de l'hydrogène
dans la mobilité routière pourquoi c'est
évidemment le plus gros émetteur de CO2
à l'échelle nationale
et quand on regarde le secteur de la
mobilité commerciale les poids lourds
les véhicules utilitaires ça représente
50% de ces émissions dans le secteur
routier on a avec l'hydrogène
aujourd'hui toutes les technologies
nécessaires pour pour accélérer dans le
monde actuellement il y a 70 000
véhicules hydrogène qui ont été déployés
c'est encore des on va dire des chiffres
limités par rapport à aux véhicules à
batterie mais on voit une accélération
par rapport à il y a quelques années où
il y avait que quelques centaines de
véhicules donc les technologies et les
acteurs les acteurs sont là on est
nous-mêmes impliqué et on a été à
l'origine du projet par exemple de taxi
hydrogène dans Paris vous pouvez voir
des flottes qui commencent à croître on
vise d'avoir 1000 taxis hydrogène d'ici
au JO on inaugure bientôt la première
station poids lourds hydrogène dans le
sud de la France
et plus récemment on a annoncé une
co-entreprise avec le groupe Total
énergie pour accélérer l'investissement
de station
le long des
de stations pour les véhicules
commerciaux le long des corridors
mais deux juste pour revenir sur deux
deux
défis auxquels on se confronte en
développant cette filière en France et
en Europe le premier c'est le soutien
l'investissement de ces stations là
comme vous l'avez vu le
la réglementation sur l'infrastructure
pour les fuel alternatifs la firent
finalement pu être conclu ces dernières
semaines elle permet de définir un
maillage minimum en Europe sur le nombre
de stations hydrogènes pour permettre
l'émergence de la filière donc si tu as
un moment où on met une contrainte sur
les constructeurs automobiles
constructeurs notamment de poids lourds
qui doivent réduire leurs émissions de
45% d'ici 2030 sans avoir totalement mis
en place un plan pour déployer
l'infrastructure de carburant alternatif
notamment hydrogène qui va leur
permettre d'atteindre ses objectifs là
donc on voit comme une vraie priorité
dans les dans les mois à venir de
définir un plan aussi bien au niveau
européen que national de soutien à
l'investissement différents exemples
existent de par le monde sur la manière
de d'inciter à la construction de
capacité véritablement et des risques le
marché
et le deuxième défi auquel qu'on voit
nécessaire pour pour accompagner cette
histoire de l'hydrogène dans la mobilité
routière c'est donner plus de
flexibilité comme je disais tout à
l'heure
au système d'accompagnement notamment
sur l'origine de l'hydrogène qui est
utilisé dans trop dans de trop nombreux
cas c'est d'hydrogène purement d'origine
renouvelable qui est qui est prescrit
dans les mécanismes de soutien on a
besoin non seulement d'élargir cela de
l'hydrogène bas carbone incluant
l'hydrogène qui serait à partir de CCS
et on a besoin de définir une
trajectoire raisonnable de décarbonation
de cet hydrogène jusqu'à 2030 pour être
capable de boucler l'équation économique
on est en train d'introduire des
véhicules qui bénéficient pas encore
d'effets d'échelle de la même manière
sur les stations on peut pas demander
simultanément d'avoir un hydrogène
renouvelable qui est également plus
coûteux à produire donc on a
véritablement besoin de flexibilité là
encore les pays qui mettent en œuvre ce
type de flexibilité
dans les pays c'est flagrants qui sont
en train d'accélérer le plus vite sur
sur le développement de la filière
secteur aérien je voudrais juste revenir
également dessus et puis je resterai là
c'est le deuxième secteur clé je dirais
pour l'hydrogène puisque il y a pas de
décarbonation du secteur aérien qui soit
envisageable sans utiliser d'hydrogène
sous diverses formes donc que ce soit
sous différents dérivés donc ça peut
être les carburants synthétiques
durables et on voit aujourd'hui beaucoup
de soutien une forte dynamique derrière
ces carburants j'ai envie de dire que
c'est entre guillemets la solution la
plus la plus simple mais comme j'ai dit
au début qui est pour certaines
questions de pérennité quant à la
disponibilité de quantité de CO2
biogénique suffisant et par rapport au
coût de ces carburants là cinq fois plus
élevé que qu'un kérosène classique
l'alternative étant l'hydrogène liquide
donc solution que que le groupe Airbus
développe très activement donc sur les
cours courrier moyen courrier donc on
voit que à l'horizon d'une d'une dizaine
d'années on pourrait avoir des solutions
totalement industrielles pérenne sur la
base d'hydrogène liquide sur des plus
petits
avions typiquement des avions régionaux
de quelques dizaines de places c'est des
un déploiement qu'on voit dès l'horizon
2027 le premier vol d'un avion hydrogène
30 places a eu lieu récemment aux
États-Unis et des compagnies aériennes
régionales françaises ont commencé à
passer des commandes sur ces avions là
donc on voit vraiment ces deux solutions
hydrogène liquides carburant synthétique
durable qui doivent pas être opposés on
doit être capable justement là de
soutenir des solutions qui sont
complémentaires et qui servent
différents horizons de temps
et on a en France
un certain nombre d'acteurs qui
permettent véritablement de de
développer une filière d'excellence au
niveau de de la promotion de l'hydrogène
liquide que ce soit des groupes comme
Airbus je le mentionnaire liquide on a
évidemment une très grande expérience
dans le domaine des technologies
cryogéniques des groupes comme FIV ou si
j'ai l'argile à d'autres secteurs Alstom
également donc une vraie opportunité
pour pour
la France de développer vraiment une
filière qui puisse ensuite s'exporter
voilà donc pour quelques quelques enjeux
j'essaie de balayer et vous montrer la
maturité dans ces différents secteurs et
puis évidemment
ravi de répondre à vos différentes
questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président merci de cette présentation
vous êtes
l'un des dirigeants d'un groupe qui
évidemment une place éminente dans dans
le domaine qui nous occupe et ce niveau
mondial vous avez un peu abordé cette
question justement de comparaison au fil
des postes que vous avez occupés et avec
la vision que vous pouvez avoir
aujourd'hui on a compris en creux que il
y avait quand même un sujet de
flexibilité un sujet de plan
d'accompagnement
et parfois des logiques d'adaptation que
vous aimeriez voir conduite ou
j'imaginez nous par l'Union européenne
ou par la France et en tout cas les deux
ensemble quand vous comparez à votre
expérience internationale vous pourriez
nous dire un petit peu mieux et de
manière concrète vous attendriez des
pouvoirs publics en l'occurrence d'une
mission comme la note qui sera appelée
cas échéant à faire quelques quelques
propositions donc quels sont devant
votre point de vue les marge de
progression les mesures qui pourraient
être utiles de recommander aujourd'hui
pour permettre à cette filière de
trouver sa place
effectivement plusieurs
plusieurs axes
un premier axe qui est puisqu'on parle
d'hydrogène
renouvelables notamment qui est de
s'assurer qu'on est dans la décennie qui
décennie devant nous disponibilité
d'électricité renouvelable renouvelable
abondante et économique on voit
aujourd'hui et vous le mentionniez tout
à l'heure que le développement de la
filière appelle des quantités de des
capacités de production d'énergie
d'électricité renouvelables
significatives et on a véritablement
besoin d'avoir déjà à ce niveau là les
mesures d'accompagnement nécessaires
pour produire ensuite cet hydrogène
renouvelable le deuxième point et vous
le reveniez sur cette notion de
flexibilité
face aux défis qu'on a pour décarboner
la mobilité notamment à l'échelle dans
sa globalité
il nous semble essentiels de prescrire
l'ensemble des des options d'hydrogène
décarbonée pour ces secteurs là donc de
l'hydrogène renouvelable mais également
de l'hydrogène à partir de fossiles et
CCS et hydrogène à partir de nucléaire
on voit dans des pays tels que les
États-Unis dans plusieurs pays
asiatiques véritablement envie de dire
ce pragmatisme cette flexibilité pour
donner l'exemple de plusieurs pays
asiatiques ils se focalise dans les
années qui viennent véritablement sur la
transformation de Laval la mise sur la
route des véhicules l'investissement de
station et sans même mettre de
contraintes sur l'origine de l'hydrogène
à ce stade là sachant que ensuite vient
une décarbonation progressive de cette
hydrogène quand on se tourne côté plutôt
américain
le plan de soutien
qui a donc soulevé beaucoup de
beaucoup d'analyses et de commentaires
ces derniers mois a aussi beaucoup de
pragmatisme on est sur un système qui
vient soutenir la production d'hydrogène
des carbonées quelle que soit son
origine de nouveau et notre
technologiement il s'appuie uniquement
sur une empreinte CO2 de l'hydrogène
produite pour définir un mécanisme de
soutien et il a aussi l'intérêt de
d'apporter une visibilité puisqu'on a un
mécanisme qui est stable sur les 10 ans
d'investissement de cette technologie là
donc qui sont des caractéristiques qu'on
soit très retrouver également en France
et en Europe
je vais poursuivre sur la production
quel est votre objectif de production
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
avoir comme objectif dans d'ici quelques
années
est-ce que vous avez des projets
on parle beaucoup d'électrolyse de
gigafactory etc est-ce que vous êtes sur
ce type de d'investissement quelle
difficulté vous rencontrez on entend
parfois qu'il y a aussi des sujets de
raccordement tout simplement avec RTE
parce que c'est le cas et quels sont vos
projets en France là dessus et puis ce
que vous nous en dire un petit peu plus
sur le partenariat que vous avez total
avec plaisir
je commencerai peut-être d'abord sur les
technologies vous mentionnez
l'électrolyse donc on a
lancé une co-entreprise avec le groupe
Siemens energy pour
bâtir un leader européen des
technologies d'électrolyse dite Pen et
on est en cours de finalisation de la
construction d'une gigafactory
d'une capacité significative de l'ordre
de 3 gigawatts qui sera démarrée en
Allemagne d'ici la fin de l'année donc
je pense que c'est intéressant à
souligner parce que ça montre
la puissance de ce moteur
franco-allemand pour
tirer tirer la filière on va utiliser
cette technologie pour des projets
d'investissement en France donc on a un
projet j'ai envie de dire vraiment
étendard en Normandie un projet de 200
MW d'électrolyse ça va être quand on le
déminera vraisemblablement le plus gros
la plus continuité d'électrolyse paie au
monde on exploite nous-mêmes
actuellement un une unité de 20
mégawatts au Québec qui est une vraie
référence pour nous pour passer à
l'échelle à l'échelle suivante on a
plusieurs projets électrolyse de cette
taille-là
en niveau très avancé de développement
en Europe notamment
au Pays-Bas et l'objectif donc pour le
groupe Air Liquide c'est d'investir 3
gigawatts d'électrolyse d'ici 2030 mais
de nouveau vous l'avez compris je pense
on est particulièrement agnostique sur
les technologies et les sources
d'énergie pour produire cette hydrogène
donc à côté de tout ce pilier
électrolyse on a un développement
également très fort sur la production
d'hydrogène par CCS donc on a
aujourd'hui probablement la technologie
la plus avancée pour capter le CO2 sur
sur nos usines on a lancé un pilote déjà
il y a 7 ans en Normandie sur une autre
us en Normandie et on est en train de de
développer de gros projets aussi bien
dans le nord de la France Dunkerque
en Belgique avec nos partenaires
industriels donc on veut vraiment
s'appuyer sur ces deux de volets pour
tripler d'ici 2030 nos capacités de
production d'hydrogène on les
décarbonant au fur et à mesure vous
demandiez juste quel type de de
difficultés en rencontre
oui quand on développe des projets
d'électrolyse les délais de raccordement
au réseau
électrique et de renforcement du réseau
électrique sont un vrai soit un vrai
problème on a le cas notamment sur un
projet
d'ampleur à Dunkerque qui impacte
directement le calendrier d'exécution de
ces projets là donc quand on voit les
objectifs ambitieux qu'on se fixe au
niveau national et européen d'ici 2030
on voit que ces problèmes là sont
vraiment sur le chemin critique dans les
années qui viennent
merci monsieur le Président
restons sur la technologie j'aurais
voulu savoir où vous en étiez dans
l'évolution des capacités de stockage
embarquer sur les véhicules légers comme
sur les poids lourds
la capacité et le poids que j'ai
l'inconvénient que ça pouvait
représenter est-ce que j'ai visité il y
a quelques années votre site à Buc et
j'ai pu voir le début du de l'évolution
des réservoirs je voulais savoir vous en
étiez la sécurité que ça vous ça nous
apporte merci pour pour la question donc
effectivement on est de cette
historiquement étant un acteur des gaz
industriels très impliqué dans le
développement des solutions de stockage
des technologies de stockage
historiquement l'hydrogène était
stockée dans des
capacités métalliques à 200 bars pour
être capable dans transporter davantage
et rendre finalement plus économique à
l'hydrogène il a besoin d'être stocké à
plus haute pression quand il est stocké
sous forme gazeuse
jusqu'à jusqu'à 700 bars et on a
développé avec un certain nombre de
d'autres acteurs des technologies
composites qui sont aujourd'hui
parfaitement mature donc je pense que
depuis votre dernière visite on est
véritablement au stade de
l'industrialisation
avec des partenaires français aussi bien
que d'autres partenaires européens
allemands notamment donc cette voie là
j'ai envie de dire est totalement mûre
et à côté à côté de cette voie de
stockage à haute pression se développe
très fortement une filière hydrogène
liquide donc là on est
l'analogie si vous êtes familier avec la
filière du gaz naturel liquéfié on est à
des températures
plus faibles à 20 degrés Kelvin mais qui
ont le bénéfice de maximiser vraiment la
densité de stockage de l'hydrogène et
c'est la solution qui va être employée
par un Airbus à bord c'est de ces avions
c'est également la solution dans le
domaine maritime pour embarquer de
l'hydrogène et nous-mêmes on développe
activement cette solution pour notre
logistique hydrogène jusqu'au point de
ravitaillement des des camions des
camions sur les routes donc des axes de
développement très forts aujourd'hui
c'est des facteurs de différenciation
pour pour un groupe commercial ou pour
la France
je t'en prie oui
que vous êtes mais c'était une formule
sans doute agnostique du point de vue
technologique et puis je crois dans le
propos linéaire tout à l'heure vous avez
employé une formule de ce type là alors
je sais pas si vous l'appliquez à la
bannière de produire de l'hydrogène ou
de manière même un petit peu plus
générale
on entend souvent comme ça des experts
nous dire
on sait pas encore il faut laisser
flotter les rubans et puis on verra bien
à un moment donné qui va gagner quelle
technologie quel mode de faire quel type
d'organisation
alors pour nous qui sommes des décideurs
publics essayons en tout cas de nous
pencher sur les sujets de mettre des
recommandations de regarder si on a la
bonne stratégie et c'est pour du recul
et faire des comparaisons ce type de
propos que scientifiquement on peut
entendre et tout de même un peu
déstabilisant
comment vous voyez les choses parce que
on aurait quand même envie parfois
d'entendre
les filières nous dire voilà comment on
planifie les choses et voilà en quoi on
peut être des solutions
et peut-être on aurait aussi envie de
mieux
organiser si ce puis dire à
décarbonation mais on est face à cette
incertitude scientifique
qui a un côté très déstabilisant quand
même mais merci bien pour la question
parce que
elle mérite précision quand on emploie
ce terme-là
c'est certainement pas pour garder
toutes les portes ouvertes ou traiter un
risque technologique une des filières
qui pourrait rencontrer des difficultés
et puis on basculerait sur une autre
c'est véritablement un enjeu industriel
aujourd'hui il produit dans le monde à
peu près 90 millions de tonnes
d'hydrogène par an très majoritairement
à partir de gaz naturel dans des unités
de réformage
il y a un intérêt immédiat à venir
investir et déployer du captage de CO2
sur cette base installée à la fois pour
réduire immédiatement les émissions de
CO2 de cette base là et permettent aussi
d'utiliser les capacités existantes pour
ouvrir des nouveaux marchés tels que la
mobilité notamment donc oui on a besoin
de ces technologies de CCS immédiatement
dans la durée on voit bien que
l'évolution du mix énergétique c'est de
sortir des énergies fossiles
et d'aller vers du renouvelable donc on
va avoir besoin de l'électrolyse et on
va avoir besoin d'une électrolyse pour
la rendre plus efficace qui soit
alimentée à la fois par une électricité
renouvelable et nucléaire donc on finit
bien par avoir les trois piliers j'ai
pas mentionné ici une autre qui met qui
a également son mérite qui est
d'utiliser du biométhane dans les
installations existantes de réformage
puisqu'on peut tout simplement
substituer le gaz naturel par le
biométhane donc on a différentes
solutions pour différents horizons de
temps véritablement
sur lesquels il faut il faut qu'on
s'appuie
et peut-être juste pour compléter il y a
trop souvent un raccourci qui est
l'hydrogène décarbonée demain doit être
d'origine renouvelable électrolytique et
on considère qu'il faut un soutien
beaucoup plus clair et probablement plus
résolu sur l'investissement de
technologie de de captage de CO2 et puis
ainsi que sur toute la filière
probablement des développements de
réseau
de canalisation CO2 pour être capable de
transporter ce CO2 jusqu'aux zones de
stockage c'est ce qui est mis en place
en tout cas dans certains pays
progressivement
sur l'aérien que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure on a compris qu'il y avait deux
hypothèses à hydrogène et puis les safs
les carburants synthétiques durables
comment vous voyez le développement
est-ce que vous mettez vous en situation
de réponse
déjà il y a des enjeux d'incorporation
et puis il y a un ange d'image pour les
compagnies il y a un enjeu de réputation
et un enjeu de responsabilité sociétale
pour ces secteurs-là avec une envie de
se décarboner au plus vite alors les
safs apparaissent la solution qui à
court terme pourrait être industrialisé
qui fonctionne qui ne posent pas de
vraie difficulté bon on a la question
des 50%
de de SAF aujourd'hui un sujet quand
même de certification ça paraît pas
insurmontable donc est-ce que vous votre
groupe se met en situation d'être un
acteur de la production et de la
distribution de ce type de carburant
on est focalisé pour ce qui nous
concerne véritablement sur la production
et la chaîne de distribution hydrogène
donc on est amené à devenir un foyer un
fournisseur d'hydrogène pour des acteurs
qui produiraient ensuite eux-mêmes leur
carburant synthétique en adjoignant
ensuite de leur côté les hydrogène avec
du CO2 biogénique
ensuite les réserves que j'ai évoquées
tout à l'heure sont pour nous un vrai
sujet comme vous dites on voit une
certaine une dynamique une frénésie
autour de autour de développement de ces
usines de carburant synthétique durable
on voit quand même qu'elles sont pas
pour demain matin on parle de capacité
de production d'hydrogène basse
électrolyse et donc des capacités de
d'électricité renouvelables en amont de
ça significative pour être capable de
répondre ne serait-ce aux quelques
pourcentages d'incorporation de de
savent dans le mix à l'horizon 2030
c'est pour ça que quand on regarde une
logique un petit peu de mérite
d'utilisation des différentes énergies
la production de savent devrait être
assez bas dans cette cet ordre de mérite
et ce qui nous semble
absolument impératifs vu les enjeux dans
le dans l'aérien
c'est en parallèle du développement de
cette filière parce qu'on n'a pas le
choix de promouvoir et soutenir c'est
une le développement d'une filière
autour de cette hydrogène liquide la
solution hydrogène liquide parce qu'on a
derrière ça des technologies à finir de
développer d'industrialiser
d'industrialiser on a demain des
infrastructures à développer dans les
aéroports nous c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a créé une co-entreprise
avec Aéroport de Paris pour déjà
réaliser la planification l'ingénierie
de ce que sera demain un terminal
hydrogène et les infrastructures de
stockage d'hydrogène liquide
donc c'est vraiment là là être capable
de mener de front de voix de voix
parallèles puisque l'aviation rosse
probablement besoin des deux dans le
futur
quel est votre prix d'objectif à la
pompe
pour le client et le coup au kilomètre
c'est une bonne question
une cible si on est en particulier sur
les usages commerciaux où on sait que
pour ces opérateurs là
chaque euro compte et peut les faire
basculer
d'une solution vers une autre on
considère que c'est dans une plage pour
être un peu large de 7 à 10 euros du
kilo pour un hydrogène décarboné
et avec un kilo alors sur un Véhicule
Passager on fait 100 km et pour un
camion un poids lourd il va falloir 10
kg pour faire 100 km
10 kg 10 kg pour pour faire 100 km
je vais vous poser notre sur un autre
plan si vous voulez puisque vous êtes
sur plusieurs pays notamment en Europe
que vous avez des actions aussi en
Allemagne quel est votre analyse
concernant les divergences stratégiques
qui apparaissent au niveau européen
notamment entre la France et l'Allemagne
comme je disais tout à l'heure on a nous
on a des on a des exemples spécifiques
de collaboration on va dire fructueuse
avec avec des
partenaires allemands donc on a on a
cette société de
développement des électrolyseurs dans le
passé on a contribué nous-mêmes à
l'investissement dans le réseau
d'infrastructures de chargement
d'hydrogène
en Allemagne c'est une initiative qui a
été lancée il y a quasiment 10 ans et
qui était véritablement pionnière au
niveau mondial
une fois qu'on a dit ça les
tergiversations de l'hiver dernier sur
ce qu'on inclut dans l'hydrogène bas
carbone en Europe il est indéniable
qu'elle ralentissent
l'ensemble de
la mise en oeuvre de tout du cadre de
soutien et du cadre réglementaire au
niveau européen et c'est évidemment
préjudiciable
par rapport à d'autres géographies qui
sont en mesure de d'accélérer
actuellement donc on a véritablement
besoin d'un alignement entre entre deux
pays sur
le sur ce qu'on inclut notamment dans
l'hydrogène bas carbone
oui tout à l'heure vous abordiez la
question de la captation ou plutôt
l'enjeu de la captation du
du CO2 et on a différents auditions
l'une des personnes auditionnées nous
nous enfin donner un éclairage
particulier sur l'utilisation du CO2
fatal pour fabriquer justement les
carburants de synthèse alors il y a
parfois des réticences pour ce type de
mesure des projets qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire des enjeux
première chose c'est qu'on est donc
nous-mêmes effectivement impliqué dans
le développement de la de la filière de
captage de CO2 avec de la technologie
qu'on a qu'on met en oeuvre d'ailleurs
chez nos propres usines sur le transport
du CO2 on a également créé une
co-entreprise avec
sogestrant une société française
appliquée dans le transport maritime
pour cheminer le CO2 jusqu'à des puits
de stockage donc pour nous cette partie
là elle devient une vraie réalité et
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure elle est
indispensable
l'autre l'autre voit qui est de
réutiliser ce CO2
on en a très clairement besoin dans la
chimie notamment on voit qu'on va devoir
recomposer finalement la pétrochimie
remplacée des sources de carbone
d'origine fossiles par du CO2 sur les
carburants synthétiques
pour nous c'est un CO2 d'origine
biogénique qui doit être privilégié si
on veut véritablement que le bilan
global sur la baisse des émissions dans
le transport soit soit au rendez-vous
réutiliser un CO2 d'origine industrielle
pour en faire des carburants
synthétiques durables réduit fortement
l'efficacité de l'ensemble de la chaîne
monsieur
le président d'abord tenez à m'excuser
pour le retard puisque avec ma collègue
Béatrice de nous étions une audition sur
une PJL donc voilà on essayait de se
partager en deux voilà non pour venir la
question vous avez parlé de
des questions de transport de
l'hydrogène
est-ce que cette question de sécurité
est pas prenante sur cette affaire là
sachant que peut-être alors ça peut-être
été posé tout à l'heure mais ce qui est
le moins le moins
susceptible de danger ce serait
peut-être le transport maritime bon puis
après peut-être le train puis en ce qui
concerne en tout cas les véhicules
routiers quel est votre approche sur
cette question là et la deuxième
question c'est pour vous qui êtes
spécialiste des du gaz des enfin des gaz
en particulier en ce qui concerne
pour vous est-ce que c'est simplement un
carburant ou est-ce que c'est un moyen
de stockage d'énergie
d'accord donc sur le premier point de la
sécurité qui est effectivement essentiel
j'ai envie de dire que c'était un sujet
qui était encore haut dans les
préoccupations il y a une dizaine
d'années quinzaine d'années
depuis
le sujet a été traité par les
industriels y compris dans ce que je
dirais l'application la plus grand
public qui est un Véhicule Passager donc
l'objet tout à l'heure vous pouvez à
Paris prendre monter dans les taxis
hydrogène les grands constructeurs
automobiles considèrent que ces mêmes
plus sûr aujourd'hui en cas d'accident
notamment
cette solution de stockage d'hydrogène
dans des dans des pour revenir à la
question précédente dans des réservoirs
qui sont extrêmement solides et
réservoirs en carbone qu'un
véhicule essence normal la raison pour
la raison derrière ça c'est d'une part
beaucoup de développements depuis 15 ans
il y a un certain nombre de standards
techniques au niveau international au
niveau européen au niveau français qui
ont été mis en place et le développement
de toute ce PlayStation d'équipements
qui permettent de mettre ça en oeuvre de
manière sûre sans parler du fait qu'il y
a quand même un vécu sur l'hydrogène
avec lui industriel très important je
faisais référence plutôt aux 60 ans
d'expérience qu'un acteur comme Air
Liquide nous avons
100 millions de tonnes d'hydrogène qui
sont produites par an donc c'est des
installations colossales avec une
accidentologie un retour d'expérience
très importante donc la mise en oeuvre
dans des nouveaux usages
se fait facilement donc ça c'est
vraiment un sujet qui est derrière nous
sur le deuxième le deuxième point alors
hydrogène en tant que que source
d'énergie dans les transports ou dans
les usages ou bien vecteurs les deux
sont critiques pour revenir justement
d'un pays comme le Japon le Japon la
Corée
vont devenir encore plus dépendants
énergétiquement qu'il l'était dans le
passé vont devoir importer beaucoup
d'hydrogène dans le futur sous forme
d'ammoniac sous forme d'hydrogène
directement
on n'est pas nous directement impliqué
dans ces filières là un groupe comme
comme Air Liquide on va on va utiliser
l'hydrogène finalement
à sa réception quand il est quand il est
transporté de manière comme ça
Transcontinental pour le mettre en
oeuvre dans des applications
industrielles ou pour la mobilité
monsieur le rapporteur
bien on aura traité dans un futur qui
est relativement proche de la de la
future PPE comme on dit la programmation
plus annuelle alors comme vous êtes
devant des législateurs qu'est-ce que
vous souhaiteriez s'agissant l'hydrogène
c'est une bonne question
j'ai cité déjà un certain nombre de
un certain nombre de d'éléments
importants dans les logiques d'amorçage
de la filière et nous sommes importants
de préserver
une activation via des grands bassins
industriels
donc le soutien
l'investissement
d'usine de production véritablement à
l'échelle donc je citais tout à l'heure
200 MW c'est 80 tonnes d'hydrogène par
jour et ça va devenir finalement plutôt
le le
la taille minimum pour pour densifier
les installations
deuxième élément qui nous semble
important c'est
de diversifier ses sources d'hydrogène
bas carbone donc pas uniquement prescrit
un hydrogène renouvelable mais
véritablement un hydrogène base
nucléaire également et base CCS si
finalement l'objectif commun est d'être
capable de faire partie des nations qui
vont déployer le plus rapidement
possible
l'hydrogène à l'échelle d'ici 2030 et de
la manière la plus économique ça nous
semble une une
[Musique]
condition sinequanone donc on a on a là
quand même deux piliers
directement un corollaire du dernier
point sur le l'hydrogène base CCS c'est
qui nous semble qu'il faut des davantage
de mécanismes de soutien pour la filière
de captage et de stockage du CO2 en
France donc avec probablement des
mécanismes de type contracts
qui puisse vraiment soutenir les
investissements d'autant plus qu'on
parle là d'investissement à faire pour
l'hydrogène mais pour d'autres procédés
industriels qui ont également besoin
d'un captage de CO2 dans leur dans leur
fumée donc voilà pour citer quelques
quelques éléments qui nous semblent qui
nous semblent importants je reviens
aussi si on permettait sur le
développement de la mobilité
où on en est mobilité hydrogène si on
veut véritablement
permettent de voir éclore d'ici 2030 une
mobilité à l'échelle on a cet enjeu de
soutien l'investissement des stations
aujourd'hui on a ça se fait par appel à
projet j'ai envie de dire ponctuel en
l'occurrence le dernier appel à projet
de l'ADEME date d'il y a 2 ans déjà et
on a besoin d'un d'une approche plus
systématique pour soutenir ces
investissements de station et là encore
de nouveau prescrire être moins
prescriptif sur l'origine de l'hydrogène
pour la mobilité
comment vous situez sur le volet
importation de l'hydrogène
pour le dire simplement je pense que la
priorité en Europe comme en France doit
être développé dans un premier temps une
base de production solide
et d'assurer véritablement cette
souveraineté énergétique qui est on le
voit on le voit de nouveau à l'occasion
du conflit
ukrainien critique et de se laisser la
possibilité
au cours de la décennie en fonction de
de la construction de la demande de voir
comment ajuster de la vitesse à laquelle
on est capable de bâtir ses capacités de
production en Europe de voir s'il faut
compléter ça avec avec de l'import par
dessus mais la priorité reste de bâtir
nos propres nos propres capacités et de
nouveau en s'appuyant sur les les
bassins industriels
particulièrement solide qu'on a qu'on a
déjà en France et du coup comment vous
appréciez la stratégie allemande parce
que
eux ils sont surtout sur un modèle
d'importation semble-t-il
parce qu'ils sont également plus
vulnérables avec
leur mix énergétique je pense que c'est
ce qui aujourd'hui nous différencie donc
pour la France si on s'appuie le fait de
pouvoir s'appuyer sur un mix électrique
à la fois nucléaire et renouvelable et
je reviens bien sur le fait que oui il
faut créer les conditions pour avoir les
capacités de renouvelables suffisantes
mais en s'appuyant sur ça et de nouveau
en poussant le CCS on a tout ce qu'il
faut pour bâtir une base de production
solide nationale
et pour être concret le pied hydrogène
comment vous voyez sa mise en œuvre
les axes du pied que
nous semblent nous semble adaptés il y a
la partie techno qui a permis qui a
permis de
soutenir un panel large de société sur
des équipements tout le long de la
chaîne donc
en l'occurrence on trouve qu'il a bien
couvert les besoins ensuite il y a la
dimension sur l'investissement d'usine
de production d'hydrogène notre projet
d'électrolyseur en Normandie bénéficient
de ce piecq
donc de nouveau il répond aux besoins si
on a quelque chose à redire c'est la
vitesse à laquelle ce type de projet se
met en oeuvre de par le processus leur
bouclage avec l'Europe on est quand même
sur maintenant 2 à 3 ans et sans en être
totalement sorti donc on voit bien que
c'est pas un rythme qui est viable pour
pour atteindre les objectifs 2030
écouter monsieur Elvis président merci
de nous avoir accordé de votre temps de
votre éclairage
et puis il y a un certain nombre de
questions qui vous ont été envoyées
c'est avec plaisir que nous prendrons
connaissance de vos réponses merci
beaucoup merci à tous les deux merci
beaucoup merci bien puis à vous enverra
ces compléments